what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel before i start do
not forget to subscribe to the channel
and bring that notification bell the way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos i apologize for the wall
we are amidst
moving
to a new place shout out to you guys for
making it possible moving to this dope
ass pet house if you want to see what
the penthouse looks like sign up for our
10 tier to get like a first look this
week also don't forget to subscribe to
the channel like the video and bring
that notification bell that way you're
gonna be notified of my daily videos
okay so today
we are talking about
i got banned off of tick tock
gasp
two years
two years of work 930 000 followers
and i have been officially banned
they've taken my account
so
this
poses the question
whenever
conservatives or red pillars try to
spread their ideas on different
platforms why are we the ones that are
banned
now why was i banned i don't actually
know for sure um i can tell you what's
been happening the last couple of months
so i would post something that women
don't like but usually has some truth to
it
um the girls will come start mass
reporting my page getting [ __ ] taken
down because you know they can't they
can't argue with you right they can't
give good arguments so they just start
getting videos taken down i would appeal
them and they would get restored but i
would still get the
issues that come with the ban like i
would still whatever ramification that
would come with the video taken down
like if i got banned for a week or
banned for a couple days whatever it was
that would stay even if the video got
restored so tick tock like gives power
almost to the people
um to the point like you can't do
anything
does that make sense like you can't
even even if you're in the right even if
they say um that they were wrong you
can't do anything
so that's frustrating um
that's really frustrating um
and
my biggest issue with this is what got
what i think got me banned the final
straw there's a couple videos but the
final straw was this video where i was
whale attacked if you guys are followed
the channel for a minute you already
know
basically
um i was out doing interviews in
this town called shortage um part of
london
and this whale
um
knocks the mic out of my hand starts
calling me a slag and so i started
calling her a whale
one of us said something that was
factual okay
slag that's just a pure insult
that's like me calling you a [ __ ]
um that's that's it sorry i live under
an airport if you hear that yeah but a
whale that's just factual that's like
calling me a ginger
you are what you are
and a lot of people get on me for like
the whale comments or the fat people
comments i have a problem with fat
people i have a problem with fat people
that are trying to say they're not fat
and that everyone should be attracted to
them
like i don't have a problem like
i got relatives that are fat they're
cool as [ __ ] they're cool as hell
but
if you're fat
and you're saying find me attractive
find me attractive like that's where we
got an issue anyways that's a whole
nother video video for a different day
the the video today we're talking about
censorship why do all these big
companies censor one side but they don't
censor the other that drew that chick
withdrew of something with a crazy laugh
she shits on men all the time no one has
an issue
but
whenever you say any criticism of women
even if it's factual
factual
i could let me see your bmi let me see
your bmi
and it was provoked i was the one that
was provoked and yet i'm the one who
suffers for i think i mean i'm not i'm
not 100 sure because it doesn't
really say why you were banned um but
i'm pretty sure that was it
because i was like the last video that i
like posted i think
um
it's not it's not fair and it's not fair
to conservatives that on all these
platforms like we have to be careful of
what we say but the women like a girl
got a national television and said that
a dude should be chopped off if he
cheats
um what if i said a girl's [ __ ] should
be chopped off when she like it's like
it's just not the same and men are seen
as so expendable that
even the at like even the different
social media apps see them as expendable
like it's it's basically okay to say
whatever about men
but whenever you put women under the
same light like men have issues
i'm not saying they don't but
it's not a fair conversation if only one
side gets to speak
so we have heard about men's issues the
last 20 years men have listened men have
gone with what women's have said
but women don't listen to men
so how are we going to have this
one-sided conversation and expect again
anyway how are we supposed to find
middle ground if we can't even have the
conversation and that's the problem is
feminists don't want to have the
conversation because it makes them look
bad
anything that puts women in a bad light
it's taken down it's censored even more
so in my opinion than like any other
group women are protected more than any
other group in my personal opinion
they're protected from criticism they're
protected from danger they're protected
like
we we live in a world where we complain
about the systems that men built to
protect us
and then we can go on a public platform
[ __ ] on men and we're still protected
and there's no appreciation for the
world that men built
and i would argue that men are the most
discriminated group against in society
and you can see it because even as a
woman i'm i'm accused of being sexist
when i talk about men's standards
um the second thing that's going viral
about me today we'll make this a
two-part
um people got mad because i said
that fat chicks don't deserve a high
value man or man that makes six figures
how is that any different than saying
that a broke bomb doesn't deserve a
victorious secret model
it's not
and
the the double like what's her face
sophia that girl that used to be on
caller daddy before they like broke up
sophia went on a podcast and said if
you're too bro you're too broke to be
dating what if we said women are too fat
to be dating
i bet it would be you know she might
agree she's skinny you know she might
she might agree get on the treadmill get
on the treadmill like and this is the
thing if you're fat you can change it
you can change it you are not stuck
being fat but
a lot of people came at me when i said
that being fat is selfish guys you can
change it you don't have to be stuck
where you are
but
and it is selfish to stay where you are
because your family's gonna have to take
care of you if you don't have the
families take care of you all the health
care workers are gonna have to take care
of you like that was one of the top
comments on that video was i'm a nurse
and i work every day having to like
break our backs trying to move these
people like someone and when you make
poor decisions with your health someone
has to deal with it and it's one thing
if you
like some [ __ ] just happens that's out
of your control like that that's one
thing but when you're you're slowly
killing yourself and everybody has to
watch you and then deal with your
problems
everyone has to watch you slowly kill
yourself and this isn't fun but it's
just a reality it's selfish to stay
overweight and i think sometimes like i
joke you know and maybe
like the the message gets lost in the
media
but
like guys i have struggled with food my
whole life i'm i've been addicted to
sugar and the number one thing if you're
looking to lose weight that i figured
out is i used to get these like
horrible pits of hunger like horrible to
the point like i could just eat a
freaking like
anything and what i figured out was when
i don't eat enough protein that's what
it comes from
so
it wasn't really and i couldn't figure
out how other people could just like
stop eating because i was like i am
always hungry and it was literally
because i wasn't getting enough protein
uh like just start eating meat whenever
you're hungry that's the first thing you
eat and see how much you eat after like
i'm not perfect and i i still it's still
something that i fight with but the
point is like you should be fighting it
obesity is horrible it's horrible for
yourself and everyone around you makes
you feel like [ __ ]
and it's hard to watch from everyone and
if we're in the society where we're
accepting that as okay and beautiful
like
it that's not it's living in delusion
because at some point somebody has to
pay for it and a lot of times it ain't
you
and that's not fair to the people around
you
um and a lot of people will say oh like
that
it doesn't matter you know but someone's
got to deal with your poor decision like
it doesn't affect you and it might not
affect me personally
um but it will affect your family and
that's just truth
or the healthcare workers taking care of
you like that that's just truth that's
just honest and why is that fair
um
yeah so but we can't have these
conversations on tick tock because
people get mad like
um i also had a tic-tac go viral where i
was talking about how women over 40 is
over for and then all these beautiful 40
year olds you know still got it started
stitching and be like oh i didn't know
it was over for me at 40. but the
question is like why are you single at
40 like that you've had
what
20 years you've been dating since you
were 20 like why couldn't you figure
something out and then they'll start
shaming you because they'll flip it to
you like why are you single and i'm like
look at i've had issues
you think like i'm when i say this stuff
i'm not saying i'm different or special
i'm not
i'm absolutely not and like i figured
out that when i
like when i when i'm trying to date a
lot of times i try to be a dude and it's
really hard for me not to just be one of
the boys and guys aren't trying to wife
up the
the girl that's one of the dudes like if
you look at my videos from a year ago i
had
cystic acne okay first of all i i was
heavier um
and i dressed homeless all the time like
look look at my videos from a year ago i
was in sweats
um and in a year
you know i mean i
okay well not not today but in most on
my shows and when i go out i'm i dress
up a lot better than i used to i cleared
my skin and i've been learning to cook
the last year
and you can't always control the results
but what you can't control is you trying
you working for better
and
i'm no different than any other girl
we're just trying to get better and
trying to fix problems so i figured out
those are my problems i'm working to fix
them but if you're 40 and you say hmm i
have no problem it's
it's i'm still gonna be fine dating but
like if you've been dating for 20 years
and you've had bad results why would you
have good results in the future if you
can't say that's a problem it's the same
thing with being fat
if you you just go through life thinking
that you're going to get a six figure
guy being overweight like
you can't even identify the problem
and the only way you can find solutions
if you identify the problem and
tick-tock doesn't even let us identify
problems and talk about our problems
because it is we are in this gynocentric
social order that shields women from bad
decisions
i'm not saying you can't look good at
40.
i'm not saying you can't get married
after 40. but
if you don't approach dating with a
level of i'm on freaking sale
i'm sorry at 40 you're on sale because
what does a guy get from you he doesn't
get kids he doesn't get youth he doesn't
get purity so you got to break your back
to to get that guy you want i'm not
saying it's impossible but again if we
don't identify problems how are we going
to come up with solutions
if a year ago i just said oh yeah let me
just be one of the boys forever let me
just
let me just have cystic acne and wonder
why men don't find me attractive forever
like
let me stay in a relationship that's not
working forever then i you can't come up
with solutions and i'm not saying i have
every single solution but we live in a
world where we can't identify problems
without being called misogynistic or
without being called that we hate women
and or
you know or girls will say oh you're not
feminine
it's just like
we're talking about problems so we can
come up with solutions
so um
yeah that's my two cents tick-tock
censors me
and
i don't understand but subscribe to the
channel like the video sign up for
memberships please that's the most
important thing you can do to help the
channel is sign up for memberships love
you guys i'll talk to you later bye